mohammed we have spent an immense amount
of time this morning talking about
Germany what will be the reaction of the
other euro members good morning tom I
think they're going to look at this and
wonder what will happen next to them
it's important to understand the nature
of the contagion that's going on it is
not economic Greece is too small it is
not financial this is purely technical
the next step if Greece continues on the
road to an exit is that we don't read
the nomination of the currency and that
is a very different element of contagion
so they're going to look forward and
they're going to be thinking now how do
we reduce our exposure to conversion and
what can do we turn institutions
particularly the ECB do to help us you
have been out front on the idea of a new
currency what do those that believe
Greece can stay and use the euro what do
they get wrong but our two narratives
that the political narrative where
everybody says we'd like Greece to stay
in the eurozone then there are the facts
on the ground Greece is now going
through what economy is called a sudden
stop when you close the banking system
you trigger cascading failure throughout
the economy and when that happens it is
very difficult for politicians to remain
in control of the economy so my call
about what happens next comes from
having observed in the past what sudden
stops due to policymakers and
recognizing that's actually very hard to
control your own destiny once you in a
sudden stop in vaani I would make note
that dr. Eliran uses a sudden stop
almost in a mathematical sense that you
have an abrupt stop and then you've got
many T decisions to make which lead to
jump conditions in the market right
exactly and that's one of the reasons
why it's so urgent I supposed to have
that not occur Mohamed you know Tobias
Kafka [ __ ] with us and he made a good
point earlier all Merkel has to do is
point out Germans that it's some of
their jobs that are at stake if Greece
leaves the euro because Germany has been
lending money to Greece and obviously
won't get it all back if there is a
default why would she not want to do
that
because one it is massive uncertainty so
even if you deliver a massive debt
reduction to Greece and Greece needs
that there are no guarantees that Greece
will come through on reforms so you have
a situation where neither side trusts
the other and in a negotiation when you
don't have trust it's very difficult to
take the first step so you have this
typical game theory in which you cannot
get a cooperative outcome and that's the
tragedy of Greece it is not how to solve
I'm an engineering perspective but it is
very hard to solve when the two sides
don't trust each other Mohamed if Greece
decides to exit this Sunday and they
effectively rip up their their debt
notes this pose is potentially a capital
problem for the ECB does it not yeah i
mean that's going to be losses
throughout the system i'm not too
worried about the ability of europe to
navigate this i think a lot has been
done in the last three years to ensure
that your Europe can navigate a Greek
exit there is one legal uncertainty
which is the video nomination it is not
clear what happens when you go from a
currency you do not own the euro the
currency you do own and you returned
innominate contracts that is the big
legal uncertainty of them otherwise
Europe has the tools to deal with later
it's actually you know how many degrees
of freedom does angela merkel have right
now phew because she doesn't control
facts on the ground increase you had a
wonderful comment earlier in the show
which which I wrote down with facts had
changed on the ground this is a
different Greece this is a group agrees
that's now in the intensive care unit it
will emerge from the intensive care unit
but it will be much smaller in terms of
the size of its economy and it's likely
to be a different economy and its veil
important to understand the facts have
changed on the ground Mohamed el-erian
thank you so much particularly for your
contributions to bloomberg view / other
weekend dr. Larian of course writing for
Bloomberg